[Music]
every director in hollywood is going to
want a shot at directing the new star
wars movie some very famous directors
who really want to do it have already
made audition tapes even michael moore
made a star wars tape look at that
[Music]
[Applause]
yeah uh hi i'd like to talk to darth
vader please whoa hey you you can't film
in here so you're gonna have to i need
to talk to your boss
sir just take the camera are you aware
that darth vader has uh destroyed
thousands of jobs on my home planet of
flintowing and i want to answer i'm
sorry sir mr vayner is vacationing uh
with his family on the planet indoor are
you aware that darth vader has illicit
dealings with jabba the hutt
let's get let's that's a known criminal
gust down here do you like working for
darth vader
yeah yeah you know he's easy i don't see
him much what's going on here
yes i'm uh here on behalf of millions of
droids who have lost their attention i
need to talk to your boss darth vader
turn this camera off off turn it off
right now please
this is a picture of an abandoned
lightsaber factory thousands of people
have lost their jobs don't you have a
heart don't you don't you care about
people don't you mr vader darth vader mr
vader i have a few questions for you
please mr doug vader i have a question
for
very good
[Applause]